pip pour terminer ce journal un bel
exploit sportif je pense que vous
connaissez tous ce cube dont il s'agit
de reconstituer toutes les faces c'est
ce qu'on appelle le rubik's cube
tout le monde ou presque est bien
aujourd'hui pour la première fois en
angleterre une compétition
époustouflante
écoutez le temps du vainqueur 39
secondes essayer de faire mieux a
londres ils étaient une centaine ce
matin à prendre part à l'épreuve de
vérité qui est le plus rapide à résoudre
les 43 milliards de milliards de
solutions du cube infernal de monsieur
rubik jamais casse tête n'a autant
mérité son nom erno rubik le père de ce
gadget diabolique n'avoue lui-même qu'un
chrono très moyen
une minute dix dans ses meilleurs jours
mais son cube lui apporte d'autres
compensations commercialisé à l'échelle
de la planète
le cube hongrois de monsieur rubik vaut
de l'or à 37 ans son inventeur et
célèbre très célèbre non seulement pour
avoir renfloué la balance commerciale de
son pays mais aussi pour avoir créé le
dernier jeu à la mode
le cube sécrète autour de lui des clubs
des t-shirts des publications et même
une maladie le cubique found le pouce du
pubis appelée ainsi par analogie avec le
tennis elbow
le jeu est donc devenu compétition et
commence même à voir sa légende des
bruits fou cours au sujet de japonais
ultra rapide qui leur constituerait en
13 secondes
ces jeunes anglais ont fait un peu moins
bien le vainqueur greg banner qui a 13
ans a mis trente neuf secondes et 2/10
moi j'ai réussi en dix minutes 30
pendant la durée du sujet